brought to you by total war warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free hey guys it is the 25th of
May today my name is Jeff and here's the
things that have been happening in
gaming first up today a bunch of room
with details about titanfall to have
landed on reddit the titanfall
subreddits moderator leaked the
information which allegedly comes from
someone in the know a leak suggested
that titanfall 2 will release in October
of this year and the respawn
entertainment's have introduced quote a
ton of new pilot abilities including the
addition of a grappling hook reportedly
the grappling hook will let you get into
Titans from a distance pull enemies out
of the air and extend freerunning maps
have also been made larger to
accommodate an increased play account in
multiplayer matches a leak also includes
artwork which notably doesn't feature a
crackling hook or the sword revealed in
the teaser so we'll have to wait and see
on the legitimacy of this one the web
domain for the allegedly cancelled preto
and the domain for prey 3 has been
updated suggesting we may hear more
about the game at e3 both websites now
redirect to a facebook page that
currently blocks viewers from seeing
content on the page which has led many
to believe this content will go live
after an announcement that said
publisher Bethesda hasn't shown any
indication of furthering the series
since its cancellation preto was
announced in 2011 but then fell into
limbo a foreign official statement on
its cancellation was made in October of
2014 Bethesda have previously said they
aren't entirely abandoning the franchise
but that they need to see what can be
done with it a whole slew of xbox room
is landed today so let's get you or cut
up almost Microsoft blogger and
podcaster Brad sounds her said sources
of indicator that two new xbox one
consoles
in development one is set to be revealed
at e3 and will be forty percent smaller
in size while the other is slated for a
20-17 announcement and will feature a
more significant hardware revision
kazakh corroborated this information and
added that this year's model is believed
to include a two terabyte hard drive
while next year's is codenamed Scorpio
and we'll have a better GPU in addition
to being technically capable of
supporting the oculus rift if that
sounds familiar it's probably reminding
you of the ps4 neo which is rumored to
do much the same thing later this year
sams also claimed that microsoft will be
announcing multiple new video streaming
hardware devices at e3 similar to an
apple TV or a google chromecast which
are expected to cost between 100 bucks
and two hundred dollars the microsoft a
blogger explained they're going to have
two devices it's going to be one for
super streamers think a Roku style
device and then another device is going
to have more features it's also been
rumored that microsoft intends to bring
the xbox interface to pc and that all
future flagship games including halo
will come to both xbox one and pc it's
already been announced to that first
party games halo wars 2 and c of thieves
will arrive on both xbox one and pc xbox
bosqueville Spencer has responded to the
bevy of rumors with a tweet Spain lots
of creative chatter today excited to
share our gaming story Eddie 3 on jun 13
microsoft to briefing is scheduled for
nine-thirty a.m. PST that day let me
know down in that comment section what
you want to see from Microsoft at e3
this year you should have stopped by
games but we've got stories on overwatch
and day sex mankind's divided that is
everything I have you today be sure to
leave me your thoughts and feelings on
today's stories and I will see you again
tomorrow